are you wearing Maryjo kylie jenner's
cosmetics line is facing some trouble
from the Better Business Bureau
the 18 year old reality star and her
company Kylie cosmetics received an F
rating the lowest score possible Oh
Kylie can't keep her famous lip kits in
stock but that's not what people are
complaining about the Better Business
Bureau stated in their report that most
of the complaints they received were
related to delivery issues get lift kits
when everyone fortunately not long after
Kylie's company bounced back and
received AC rating according to the
Business Bureaus CEO Rick Copeland the
initial F grade was due to the BBB not
being aware of the true volume of
business Kylie cosmetics was putting out
I have just been putting my energy where
Kylie has seemingly been involved in
every step of her lip kit production
often posting snapchats while she's at
the factory and swatching new colors new
children lip kit creator even teased
this on snapchat last month that she may
soon be opening a cosmetic store looking
for Kylie cosmetics stores